hi my name is Timothy Oliphant and I
feel
blendiferous okay being Conan O'Brien
not a word
um doesn't exist
you know let me tell you something first
of all oh yeah and you and this is a
compliment to you now when people say
that it never is like your face isn't as
wide as it is tall it is a word right
what splendiferous is it I don't think
so is it a word I doubt hold on
uh okay because the only
reason I know this word oh so is because
Elvis Costello said it about this he
that was his answer give it more
listening no I but I'm not going to cook
it's all a blur to you I'm not gonna
correct Elvis Costello oh but me yes you
because I've got you and I have beef
that goes back a long way that's true
the last time you were on the podcast
um you were disrespectful you
disrespected not just me but the whole
Forum differently you know memory is not
a reliable narrator
if you made you did random ads yourself
for I believe made up products just to
try and get money keep it up I'll break
them out now no no no please I forget
one of them was at tennis your teeth I
do brush my teeth how about those quips
they're just gonna send you a free quip
you're not gonna get any cash I just I
didn't realize this morning I could use
one those are uh those are handy yeah I
don't remember what happened on the the
podcast first of all let me say thank
you for having me back of course thank
you for having me on the first time I'm
sorry it didn't go well
and said I learned nothing and way too
much
I will tell you this is our first
go-around okay I'll tell you this and
and Adam uh sex you can weigh in I
believe I'm quite certain that your
podcast your first part podcast one of
the most uh beloved by fans and
universally every so often online every
few months there's a message board
that's like what are your list your
favorite conaf episodes every single
time there's a list made yours is in the
top five well I thank you both for
telling me that and let me just a
special message to those people
prepare to be disappointed no no no no
no Ed Conan hit me with your first
question
[Laughter]
the other day and I really I really want
to uh this is important and for the
listeners yeah I want this to be more
about you and and um and your
performance this is not about me right
now okay so ask good questions okay
because you know what I mean you did you
did text me yesterday and said please
ask me good questions you threw the
first shot by saying we would meet up
later for drinks or dinner and that it
would be fresh the podcast would be
fresh in your mind and you would judge
me yeah I'll judge you on your
performance how's it going so far uh we
heard a solid C minus let me tell you
something we're this thing is killing it
already I can just tell you feel it
right there's an energy no that's an
aneurysm uh
I I'm first of all you you uh you're a
delightful fellow and we are friends in
real life so much so
that uh I have this guy that works for
me who's well known to my fans Jordan
schlansky and uh I taped a segment with
him recently and we put it out on the
internet and he has this moment where
he's just furious furious with me that I
didn't keep him employed after we fully
employed I pay him uh half salary
because there's nothing to do when the
late nights talk show stopped and until
we start the next project and he's
Furious that he's only getting half the
money to do nothing
and I start to defend myself and he says
what are you doing anyway and then he
says to me with this contemptuous sneer
you have your dinners with Timothy
Oliphant and I swear to God I've been
hearing from so many people who love
that line that that's what's in I mean
Jordan is jealous deeply deeply jealous
of our friendship you know that well I
know it now and I think a lot and I sat
through patiently while you told that
story and now I know
I don't know ask the listeners is there
a chat board somewhere no we can't
afford that
um have you been yes are we going to do
this for real okay I haven't seen you in
a while well we haven't talked in a
while you were busy you were shooting
projects you were in Wales I believe for
a while I wasn't I was well I was in
Wales I found myself in Wales were you
not in Wales no I was in Wales okay you
were in Wales shooting some project the
kids have left the what they're commonly
referred to as empty nesters that's what
we are and so now
um
you know I just turned to uh my wife and
say you want to go to Wales and then we
then I say all right I'll take it I'll
take the job you'll take the job yeah
she's up for going you know what's Wells
is lovely your wife let me tell you
about whales oh okay I was about to say
something nice about your wife well you
took so much time with that last story I
feel like it was not a story that wasn't
a story it was relating to you how you
uh have impacted my life recently in a
Jordan remote so I didn't think that
that was
when you're in Los Angeles you feel like
Los Angeles is the center of the world
and when you're in New York you feel
like New York is the center of the world
and when you're in Wales you're like
London is the center of the world
not a lot going on there you know what
they're good people good people fun to
hang out and get drunk with yeah and
then get in fights so I left my like my
childhood Modesto and Wales more in
common than you'd think yeah Modesto
pretty tough place to grow up yeah the
Mean Streets of Modesto yeah I grew up
on a mayonnaise Farm
good crop this year huh I love that
mayonnaise bacon out there in the sun on
the old mayonnaise Farm you bet you uh
Tina I've got to tell you something what
do you got I can't relate to you because
uh Eliza and I are not empty nesters yet
you are because you and Alexis had
children when you were still
in your 20s you had your kids that's
that's kind of you to say but that's not
ex I think we were 30. I think you were
in your 20s okay and I'm gonna tell you
something else I have a very different
scenario
uh my children were born when I was in
my 60s yeah and as a result
um and now they're in their 40s yeah do
the math I'm just saying you're such a
young free guy yeah and you've got these
uh very uh cool kids who are adults now
it's they're young adult yeah that's
what I'd call them and I got to be
honest with you because I thought uh
throughout their childhood I thought we
I thought we had a good chance they'd
they'd grow up to be average and um you
told them that often right yeah you know
that's a good thing to tell a kid a lot
of pressure just before just before you
turn out the light
I was like I said I was like honey
I think you got a good shot at just
growing up to be average
to Canada moved to Canada and have a
nice life you know what I mean what's
wrong with average exactly
that's what I told him yeah and uh but I
gotta say I I I feel like they gotta I
feel like they're they might be above
average I'm enjoying them you know I
mean now that they're you know now that
they're a little older
I'm impressed and I say to my wife I
said you did a good job thanks for
raising those kids yeah where were you
the whole time uh show business you know
what I mean I took I went to I had to go
act and uh yeah and and take naps in my
trailer
took a lot of jobs for the nap time yeah
did you did you bring your family to set
much on you know I mean first of all you
can't have kids around on the Deadwood
set every other word is and
you can't have kids around
they came out once I've told this story
but
they came out once they were quite Young
when we did that show and once that I
remember and uh and ran around and and
uh and one day I was I was about to head
off to work it was breakfast you know
they're all sitting around and I was
like God I gotta go part you
know and then I thought I don't want to
place this burden on them you know that
that you know hate going toward my job
so I stopped like it was a teachable
moment and said you know actually guys
you know I really do enjoy my job you
know it's sometimes it's hard to leave
right but I but I love my job and I said
taking him a step further I said you
know you know what I love about my job
and my son goes the mud
there's a lot of mud in Deadwood that's
what he said yeah I said yep and I I
just tried to press forward by the way I
thought no yes but but also and my
daughter says the horses and I said
that's it I'm leaving the mud and the
horses pretty sweet cake though I kind
of get it I guess that in a way they
then they're right
um you know what I'm noticing about you
how are your kids doing no no you don't
listen I had a whole thing in mind I
have all these questions oh do you and
I've I haven't seen my kids in years
um there's various reasons for that but
you have your agent call once a week
tell them you love them well actually no
my manager calls then she calls my
manager then checks in with the kids
calls my agent who calls my business
manager there it is who then uh calls
the uh the accountant yeah and then I'm
told that the children are well they're
they're nourished
and they think well of their father
that's nice and so and the the LIE gets
relayed back to you by who
well naturally that would be the agent
the manager they're the ones that really
lie